tu sais moi je ne commente joséphine et
augé strictes pour le mercier
second souci je vois que c'est pas ta
place ici
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
grattez un texte avec lopez entre les
quartiers de merde et primes communiquer
les coordonnées de la personne qui a
effectué ses livraisons ça vous dirait
un petit exercice de chant quoi l'on
bruit en fait vous êtes avachi on peut
pas chanter avachi
et bien sûr sans footeux bélanger hors
de question que cet énergumène intègre
alentours jamais cessé de recruter les
meilleurs qu'est ce que tu fais là juste
qu'on appelle la discrimination positive
non
alors rendez compte de la différence là
c'est ouf et ça c'est le nom que je
cherchais c'est ouf
[Musique]
c'est quoi le soutien
c'est un complot téléphone tu lâches
début
non pas tous nous respectent pour nous
montre depuis le début
[Musique]
vous avez cette étincelle est
essentielle
il ne vous reste plus qu'à croire en
vous
[Musique]
j'ai un petit cadeau pour vous pour nous
dans le rap c'est vraiment une légende
quoi c'est comme pavarotti de pâques
tupac
[Musique]